Hello everybody, welcome back!
Welcome back!
I believe part?
Seven?
Wow!
And the menu changed again.
Very cool.
I don't quite understand.
I'm nervous about what is happening with the turrets and the
cubes.
hmm we shall the music is very dire do do do do do do after
the embarrassment of the last part I hope that we have a
smoother sailing today I'm afraid to read the comments of
the previous part but I am also it is midnight my time so
we'll If my single brain cell can conjure up any meaningful
thoughts.
Yes.
But yeah, let's get into it then.
Let's get back into it.
Hello?
The itch.
Chapter 8.
What is happening?
Oh, oh my gosh.
Does that say weeley Laboratories?
He's rebranding.
Oh my gosh.
What is happening here?
Oh, GLaDOS, what is happening here?
Ooh, the music is so different.
For God's sake, your boxes with legs.
It's literally your only purpose.
Walking onto bugs.
How can you not do the one thing you desire for?
Someone's having a bit of a...
Wait, is this a door that opens?
No.
Someone's having a little bit of a ta...
Oh.
to get us down there i'll hit him with a paradox warmer
warmer boiling hot boy okay cold ice cold your arctic man oh
my god they're like zombies now what are these two doing oh
that's funny is it always funny because we've been in this
for 12 hours and you haven't solved either so don't while
you're laughing you've got one hour solve it that's like
that's like me that's that is me this for 12 hours and you
haven't solved it.
Oh my golly goodness.
They can't shoot at me now though, right?
They're boxes with legs.
They don't have guns, right?
They sound like little critters.
Get us in there, she says.
Gotta hit him with the paradox.
How has he not noticed that we're back.
Wheatley Snoopman?
Ah, we don't.
We don't.
That's no question, right?
Are they gonna notice me?
Hello?
What's you doing?
What are you doing?
Oh my gosh, they're so cute.
Look, I'm one of you!
I'm in my turret cosplay!
They're like little...
They're like chittering.
It's so cute.
Solve this puzzle for him.
Ha ha, yes.
I knew you'd solve it.
Hey, you're on.
Oh.
Hello.
All right, paradox time.
Um, true.
I'll go true.
Yeah, that was easy.
I'll be honest.
I might have read that one before, though.
Sort of cheating.
It's a paradox.
There is no...
Uh, false.
I'll go false.
Oh, oh.
I thought I'd fix that.
I think he just unplugged it.
It turns out I'm a little bit short on test subjects right
now, so this works out perfect.
And off we go.
Wait, what does it say here?
I can't read whatever this part is, but it says really
laboratories.
Oh my god.
What has he done to you guys?
And off we go.
need to listen to you mister okay I probably should you have
no idea what it's like in this body I have to test all the
time or I get this this itch you know it must be hardwired
into the system oh but I'll tell you what I do test oh man
alive nothing feels better it's just I just that's why I've
got a test that's why I've got a test oh no he's itching for
the test you're gonna test thing is going to be just warning
core overheating nuclear meltdown i think we're in trouble i
think we're in trouble too glados what do we do oh no test
hello number one test this is a little bit difficult you'll
notice the moat area there yes very deadly extremely
dangerous eventually it's not i'll push the button Is, oh,
well .
Oh, well then.
Ew, he's getting off to this.
I think I'm done testing.
I think I'm done.
I don't think I wanna test any more.
I do not... I do not consent.
I do not, I do not consent.
I do not consent.
Yeah, you're not done yet, are you?
Still gotta get through the door.
Oh, Carly.
Oh, look how cute they are.
They look so scared.
They're shivering.
If you're cold, he's cold, let him in.
Okay.
Still going, still going again.
Oh, that's not really good.
Oh, here's an idea.
Since making tests is so difficult, why don't you just keep
solving this test?
It's like, what?
And I can just, like, watch you solve it.
Yeah, but that sounds much easier.
Ew!
You're not gonna, wait, that's like a test fetish.
Here we go.
Now, do it again.
There has to be some way I get out of this, right?
Unless I'm stuck in a loop?
Nothing.
All right, can't blame me for trying.
Okay, new tests.
Okay, okay.
New tests.
Got to be some tests around this.
Did I get achievement?
Oh, do the same test twice.
Oh, that's how you get that achievement.
That's so funny.
No way.
That's hilarious.
It's because he doesn't get off to it.
That's disturbing.
So my paradox idea didn't work.
No.
Oh.
Luckily, by the looks of things he knows as much about test
building as he does about logical contradictions.
Next one is gonna be like every, every turret pointed at me
and he's like, solve this test.
Getting out alive.
It shouldn't be hard to stay alive long enough.
Stay alive.
Oh my gosh, the song, she said the thing.
I'm still alive.
It's alright.
Everything's good.
I just invented some more tests.
This is one of my tests.
Not entirely.
Look at the word test there on the wall.
That's brand new.
Oh, wait, what is this thing?
Also, it says we're at test number one.
Wait.
Ooh, what is this?
Oh, it's wet.
Okay.
Oh.
Sad little guy.
Um, let's see.
Uh...
Where can I...
Oh, if I...
I forgot about these, actually.
It's been a while, right?
Uh, we need it, like, here.
There we go, there we go.
Ooh.
It's been a minute since we've done these ones.
Oh.
Alright.
Oh, I...
No, that was so close.
I got a little overzealous there.
Slight miscalculation.
We're fine.
everything is okay look at this though it's mesmerizing wow
okay thank you and how do i get you through this is one of
my tests she says oh
i didn't mean for that to be the case okay hold on can i
there we go come here come here baby baby we're going
together through oh oh you're here yeah you're here
goodbye goodbye oh wow well done seriously both of you why
don't why don't you two go on ahead yeah i'll just i'll
catch her with you this is so gross this is disgusting Eww!
I don't like this!
I'm uncomfortable!
Eww!
Okay, so the bad news is the tests are my tests now.
So they can kill us.
Oh, they can kill us.
Well, done so far, to be honest.
I'll get back to you on that.
Okay.
Love that.
Really happy.
We're back to the, uh, to the, uh, test, um...
Oh!
To the test loading screens as well.
I can't.
Sorry.
You're on your own.
Okay.
That's fine.
This is kind of fun, though.
We're back to the classics.
Right?
Yeah, made this test myself.
Oh, smaller tests that I found lying around.
Jammed them all together.
Buttons, got funnels, bottomless pits are involved.
It's got it all.
Absolute dynamite.
Oh, I thought he meant that there was dynamite in it.
Okay.
Leap of face?
Tool?
Uh...
Don't go.
Tool?
Err, don't go.
You're getting off to this, you sicko.
We have to go back down this way.
Wait, hold on.
Wait, no.
Oh, uh, here?
Yeah.
Wait, oh.
All right, okay, this is taking too long, okay?
I'll just tell you how to solve the test, okay?
See that button over there, all right?
You just need...
Oh!
That's why I can't hope you solve the tests.
Wait, I got so lucky there, you guys.
Never mind.
Solve it yourself.
That was crazy.
I thought I was about to die.
And I lived!
I might be a secret genius.
This one?
Ow!
Oh, we have to bring here.
him over now okay okay oh one
second my mouse has stopped responding hello I can't move
off
and on okay there we go that was freaky let's see um and it
is orange all right and from There.
There.
Oh, me too.
And from here.
Don't move.
No, don't move.
Oh, yes.
Well done.
All we had to do was pull that lever.
Good one.
I like that she's on our side now.
now all right let me in did i say please stay calm is that
what this is saying aperture laboratories no hui tli it's
not even centered this guy
oh then where will he get his fix i'm coming coming don't
start yet don't start yet You are not going to believe this.
I found a sealed off wing.
Hundreds, hundreds of perfectly good test chambers.
Just sit in there.
Filled with skeletons.
Shook them out.
Good as new.
Skeletons.
Right, I get...
Flatters.
I definitely thought he meant something else, though.
Oh.
Um.
Oh, the...
Oh, it's got...
Okay.
We're doing it live.
Oh.
I think he's stupid I think he's stupid oh my god oh how do
I get up there great question yeah great question don't.
We'll do this.
What did I do?
Orange or blue?
And then we'll do this.
Oh, there I go!
Oh, wait.
This doesn't lead where I thought it would go.
Ouch.
We need to go through that one.
Not bad.
Okay.
into you?
There we go.
Ooh, the vortex.
Ooh, the claw.
Wow, it's beautiful.
Looks like a Minecraft.
Diamonds.
You know, when you have a certain shader that makes the
diamonds light up.
That's what it reminds me of.
What's that?
Okay.
And this falls...
Hmm.
How can we catch?
You like this?
Oh!
Just so close.
So close.
This one.
For sure.
But how do I...
Can I grab it?
That's kind of far, no?
What is this?
Oh, this is...
the launcher it
launches me there but I guess I would need this to be going
how do I oh like this like this like this all right take you
though the button is up there all right can this does this
thing walk oh it does kind of hop around that, doesn't it?
Uh, we need you to not do that.
Okay.
Anyway, um...
Come here.
Wee!
Okay.
And then... Right there.
We need you to, um...
Hmm...
Me too.
I grab you.
We go in here.
We launch it.
Actually, I let you go here.
We go.
We go through together.
And you...
Oh, here we go.
Here it comes.
Ew, he knows.
Oh, disappointed.
Uh-oh.
What do you mean, disappointing?
That was, like, such a great solve.
What are you talking about?
What?
Now I'm getting upset.
I'm doing a great job!
It's happening sooner than I expected.
Oh, she's...
I'm sure we'll be fine.
She knows.
Uh-oh.
We don't even get a nice little post-puzzle screenery.
She's getting lazy.
Oh.
I do like that we're kind of back to the game.
these classic puzzles though remember your evacuation
training yeah look for a way out please i mean wrong game
all right so that last test was seriously disappointed
apparently being civil isn't motivating you so let's well
let's try her away all right fatty adopted fatty fatty fatty
no parents what what exactly is wrong with being adopted
what's wrong with being
Um...
Lack of parents?
For the record, you are adopted and that's terrible.
I'm all true?
Nothing.
Well, some of my best friends actually are awful.
Also, look at her, you're a moron.
She's not fair.
Yeah!
I am not a moron!
Just do the test.
Little baby!
Wait, I thought I got all you guys!
Wait, what's over here anyway?
Hello!
Hehehehe.
Are you still there?
Oh, it's really shutting down.
Target lost.
All right, let's see.
We have our box there.
Anything around here?
Was there any portal-bull-bull places in here?
I don't see any.
So I think maybe we do like this.
What if I do this?
It doesn't pick him up?
Wait, maybe over a little?
Oh, there he goes!
Goodbye!
Never to be seen again.
That's so sad.
What does this do?
Oh, it reverses it!
Oh, but if I do this, I'll the button.
Okay, what we do is this.
Bring... bring her to me.
Bring her to me.
Yes.
Okay, but um, hold on.
Put you there.
Put this like up there.
Okay.
All right, don't move.
Here I go!
have to get up there don't I how do I get up there actually
wait how do I get up there I can see that I like go through
like go through to here wait let me go through and see what
happens if I'm up here how do I get over there
Hmm, I'm curious.
Excuse me!
Thank you.
Oh, I see it!
I see it!
Oh.
Now that's a problem, isn't it?
I think we gotta push you away.
Yeah, alright.
Then we do this.
It's not enough!
If I'm such a moron, why can't you solve a simple test?
I just solved it!
What do you mean?
I got to the door!
I pushed that moron thing a little too far this time.
He's eggy.
Wheatley has anger problems, I think.
I had a feeling, though, calling him a moron thing was going
to come back.
Oh, now he's playing classical music.
This is so classy.
Oh, sorry, sorry, sorry.
I hope that didn't disturb you too much then.
it was the sound of books pages being turned so that's just
what i was doing just reading uh books so not a moral anyway
just finished the last one just know the hardest one
machiavelli do not know what all the fuss was about i mean
just studied perfectly have you read that one yeah that's it
well on with the test wish there was more books well there's
not there's not um oh whoa you think of I, let's see where I
fling to.
Whee!
Okay, we got that up there going on.
So we need to somehow get into the path of the...
Of you.
Hmm.
How curious once we're there, what do we do?
Yeah, so curious.
What if I...
Oh, whoops.
I think I'll go over it though.
So what, uh...
Which one is that blue?
If it's like this...
I think maybe I can like...
Wait.
Oh.
No, I think...
I messed up.
Hmm, this one's tricky.
This one requires, like, what are these for, you know?
I have to be caught, maybe.
Ah!
In the middle, perhaps, but then I don't know.
Oh, I wonder.
I think I get a...
Okay.
I fall from high up and I launch.
Okay, I got it.
I got it.
Okay, so I do, like, orange and then, yeah, I do orange here
and it'll launch us.
Easy!
Oh, I need a...
Oh, no, wait.
Where are you?
Wait, where are you?
Oh!
Ah, I see.
Okay, I have to do the same exact thing!
But for our little friend.
Where does it go?
Oh, it drops from up there.
I see it.
All right.
And then orange.
Thank you.
Oh, what?
Who was that?
That was nothing.
Oh, my God.
You're so hard to please, Weedley.
This guy is whoopy hen.
Oh, and he doesn't.
me i was in it for the science him though he just wants the
high he's getting he wants to get off to it i think wheatley
would go on heart drugs i don't say that lightly i think
wheatley still would have a problem oh
i think we're in trouble press any key to vent radiological
emissions into atmosphere that doesn't sound very good oh i
think we're like in a lot of trouble oh gosh you guys number
six just moving the old test chamber a little bit closer to
me um out of thought maybe proximity to the test solving
might give us stronger results it won't what was that oh
sorry i could have sworn you said something oh wait we're
actually like moving towards him little turrets down here.
Oh, look at that.
Wow.
Okay.
What is going on in here?
Oh, this is the, oh, it's the shield.
I remember.
Oh, I almost fell.
Oh my gosh, I almost fell.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
And then where does it fall?
Oh, but as soon as I pass through there, as soon as I pass
through there, it's gonna, they're gonna, it's gonna disable
My portal.
Oh.
What does this send me where?
Bless you, little primate brain.
I'm not actually in the room with you.
I like technology.
It's complicated.
You can't hurt the big old god face.
Oh my god.
I wasn't trying to kiss you or anything.
Weirdo.
Oh my gosh.
He has such a high ego.
All right.
I'm trying to see.
We have walls here.
up here.
Oh, I think I need to, um, maybe it was like around here
that it stops it, right?
Yeah!
Oh my gosh, perfect.
How do I get it through there?
I have to take it around over here.
Oh, take it around the back.
Yes.
So let's, um, Put this back down here, for now.
If I jump...
Hmm, okay, hold on.
Ha!
Okay.
That was scary.
All right, all right, all right.
Um, I just need to put...
I need to be, like, super duper fast about it, right?
Um...
We have orange there.
As soon as I do this, I need to go.
If I want to put the orange there, right?
You know?
So...
We could probably use him as a little shield.
Or something.
Go!
Ah!
Okay, we right.
We're okay!
Everything worked out!
We're totally okay!
How do I reach that?
Hey!
Oh, so close.
You could have walked to the...
Oh, I can't.
I get it, I get it, I get it.
Okay, come here, come here.
Come here, come here.
We're figuring it out.
We're thinking with portals!
Oh, you sucker.
I didn't even...
I didn't even let you go.
You did that all on your own.
I'm butterfingerish, man.
Okay, okay.
Okay, will they get me from behind the thing or am I safe?
I don't think I'm safe.
I'm gonna leave you here.
Don't walk away.
And we're gonna put this there.
Alrighty.
Listen, I don't think I'm safe.
But this is even scarier.
Oh.
I don't trust it.
Good enough, good enough, good enough.
Are you absolutely sure you're solving these correctly?
I mean, yes, you solved it, but I'm wondering if...
Maybe there's a number of ways to solve them, and you're
picking all the worst ways.
No, no, that was the solution.
Ah, what am I missing?
Oh, I can't shoot through there.
Oh, oh, I see, I see.
Nice.
Yahoo!
Okay.
Oh, he's blinking now.
Uh-oh.
I wish his little brain would melt.
And I emphasis on the little.
I think so too.
This is not good.
Oh, this is not good.
Ha ha ha ha.
How to brainwave.
I'm going to take you solving these and then watch Ted.
at once get a more sort of concentrated burst of science oh
on a related note I am gonna need you to solve these ten
times as fast anyway just give me a wave would you before
you solve this one all right I don't want to spoil the
ending for when I watch it later what a freak he's such a
freak he's such a freak all right let's see how to figure
this okay so there's a button up here does this does this
look yes okay good there's a that leads to there
Which we can use to launch.
Where do we need to?
Oh, this also needs to be activated.
Wait, hold on.
Let's see.
If I activate this.
Oh, actually, how can I activate it?
Okay, wait, there's so much going on here.
Alright, um, if I put this here.
and like that and then we launch will I get enough air to
get over there let's see I don't think so I don't think so
but it was worth a shot yeah I don't know why that gave me
the the the tummy you know when you know when you have that
feeling the pit of your tummy when you do a drop on a ride?
Ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh.
Wait, what's in here?
Oh, what's that?
The beam!
The beambender!
Oh, okay, okay, okay.
Ah, hmm.
Ah, but I think I will get stopped by this.
So I need to really...
What can I use?
Oh, geez.
Wait.
wait let's go through oh sorry I thought I was gonna land
right on the okay wait here oh here yeah yeah okay oh I'm
trying I'm struggling figure there's so much to do I'm
struggling figuring out the order of operations here I think
first things first we need to get this guy so we can block
that so then we can get the bender so how do because we need
to bend it so that I can portal it to here so that we can
power this for the exit so to get to this guy.
Is there anything?
I launch.
Let's see.
I launch to here.
Hmm.
Um, there's not even like a...
Huh.
Like I'm wondering.
I'm wondering if I can use this, but...
Or like this to...
I need you!
How do I get to you?
What's going
on?
Ooh, you're so cool.
We love the atmosphere of this game.
It's so awesome.
Okay, hold on.
There's nothing in here either, right?
Oh, no.
I don't think so.
What?
This doesn't do anything?
When I press the button, I'm guessing it just...
Wait, let's see what happens.
Oh, it lowers that.
Okay.
Oh, okay, okay.
Let's see if there's anything we can see from up here.
Any new perspectives?
Do you think I can make it?
Wait...
Oh!
Oh, I can do it from here!
Oh, oh, oh!
I can do this!
Yes!
Okay, awesome.
Okay, then we bring you down here.
Don't move.
Stay right there.
Okay, good.
He can't move.
Um...
Where does this lead me to?
Okay, cool.
And then, we do...
Like, like so, I think.
Would work, probably.
Ah, yeah, baby!
Okie dokie.
Place block.
Second block.
Block, block.
And...
Ouch!
Sorry, I'm really stupid.
I forgot that I need to get up here first!
Okay, okay.
This is fine.
Alright.
You and Orange.
Alright!
Let's go!
But I need you as well.
Wait, I need... I do need you.
Actually.
Because I need him for that.
Okay.
Before we...
Um...
Before we do that, let's, uh, let's bring you back.
And we'll put you right...
Yeah.
Don't move.
Don't move, don't move.
Yeah, there we go.
Okay.
And then we do...
This...
And we do that.
Very good, very good.
Okay.
Now...
Oh, all I have to do is this.
Oh, but I need that powered.
That's right.
I was like, wait a second, I know how to unpower this, but I
need that powered.
Is there a way that I can move it?
This guy's just chittering away over here.
Are you okay?
Oh, you look kind of freaked out, actually.
I don't...
It doesn't look like it has two eyes.
It looks like just like two things with one eyes.
You know what I mean?
I like its little pincer, though.
It's cute.
Okay, back to goal.
Back to goal.
How do I move this?
Oh, wait!
I know!
We can...
Watch this.
Oh.
Wait, wait, yes.
Watch this.
I might be a genius.
I think I'm redeeming myself from last part.
Would you guys say so?
You just solved it, didn't you?
I told you to tell...
You've been watching this all the time!
Why are you making this so hard for me?
Oh wow, goal!
You were watching, no!
What else were you doing?
Awesome.
I think I'm redeeming myself from last part.
You guys think so?
Oh, yes.
There is no chat, but I'm reading only yeses in the chat.
Yes, Minto.
You had a slight malfunction.
Your facility.
stream, not stream, sorry, last time, last part, but this
part surely is your golden hour.
This place is self-destructing, you idiot.
Was, was self-destructing, already fixed.
Programmed in one last tremor for all times, though.
Two, like one or two more tremors in there just for fun.
Morning.
Core, I'm reading.
I like to keep it strong.
I'm not a monster.
Ignore what I say, though.
Just keep on testing.
Oh, whoops.
what does this do oh oh what that is what does it do oh is
there like a laser oh there's a laser beams got it very cool
very cool is there a bouncy to the other side or um what
what the heck am i supposed to do oh wait i just need the
portal over no
um this is quite curious now isn't it and what about this
one what does this bottom one do
okay so these come over Oh, then they go back.
And I need to make sure that everything is in order.
Maybe I can keep this one.
Oh, wait, but it needs to be running, huh?
Wait, actually, what if I do this?
When they get over there?
I press...
Blue!
Okay.
Alright, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah, yeah.
Okay, nice.
Alright.
now they need to be running and also I need to not get well
they're pretty long right so what we could do is I move
which one makes me move oh okay we start moving oh whoops
wrong one this one all right once we get to the very edge I
need to make it not move, so I will need to...
Oh, oh, oh, there we go, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah,
yeah.
Okay.
Oh, oh.
Blue!
Okay.
All right.
Good job.
Good job, me.
Blue.
Okay, okay, okay.
Blue!
Buy some.
Oh, we need to time that now, don't we?
Yeah, we do.
Did I miss?
No, I didn't miss!
I didn't miss!
It's up there!
Alright, I need to do the same exact thing that I did
before, so keep going.
Go back to the other side.
We'll portal up there once it's over there.
Onto it.
Wait, but how will I get home?
Maybe that's good enough?
Ouch!
Uh...
There we go.
There.
Okay, um...
Let's see.
I think we have to do the same exact thing again.
Oh, but how do I redirect it?
When I'm on the other side.
You know what I mean?
Okay.
This one to move, right?
The bottom.
I'm just trying to figure it out where I can...
I might be able to run and jump if I'm close enough, right?
So let's try that.
Alright.
This freaks me out when it doesn't start immediately, you
know.
Alright.
Blue!
Okay.
Wee-woe!
Wee, wee, wee, wee.
Okay.
I can make that.
But it's Sarm.
Oh.
Yeah, we can.
We can laser it.
Oh, no.
I am harmonizing.
Oh, it's all.
Well,
surely, if I bring this over there with me, we could just do
it from there, right?
You know what?
Let's try.
I give up.
Golly.
Okay, let's just do it from here, y'all.
Oh, I can't get up there.
Why did I think that it was so low to the ground?
No!
I made a whoopsie pupsie.
But even the placement now...
I guess...
My only thought is I...
I...
I have to be pretty on top of it, you know?
Like I can't... I don't think I could direct it.
from like like standing here if it's right there oh I'm like
on the the test is on the solution is on the tippy tip of my
tongue I wish I could just get up there more easily
we definitely need to get back up there though that is That
is a fact.
That should be good.
Oh, I don't know why.
Whatever.
Because there's just no way, there's nowhere for me to
portal from over here.
Everything is too high up.
No way to launch myself.
As well.
We're like so close you guys.
We're like so close.
Okay.
That's passing through there.
Alright, come over here with me, pal.
Buddy, oh, pal of mine.
What if I just went through the lasers really fast?
You know?
What if I went through it really fast?
Which one is it?
Blue?
Okay, orange.
Actually, if I do this...
Wait a second.
How do I even direct it?
Wait, I'm too low.
I'm too low.
Oh, this changes a lot of stuff.
What if...
I can do it through there.
Wait.
It might need to come through here.
Yeah, it needs to come through here.
And then I...
Okay, okay, okay.
Okay, okay.
Wait, that changes everything!
Oh, that changes everything!
Oh, whoa, whoa, whoa.
I think I need it to be over a little tiny bit more.
Okay.
Alright.
Yes!
Ta-da!
How do I get home?
I can just- I can- it's set up that way.
I can just reset it.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
I can just reset it this way.
We can do it.
Yeah.
How do I get home?
You go like here?
Oh, it's still nothing.
Let's keep moving.
It's out of service because it melted.
It melted.
Oh, it melted.
Oh, okay.
Might as well, you know, give me the tour.
To your left, you'll see some lights of some kind.
Don't know what they do.
Very science.
Oh!
Oh, go around.
That's not supposed to be there.
Ah!
Are you all right back there?
Here, I'll turn the beam off.
Oh, wait, wait, wait, wait.
Oh, no, no, no, no, that's not helpful.
I don't know why I thought that would help.
Oh, I kind of feel bad for him.
It's not his fault if he's programmed to be stupid.
That sounds terrible, though, doesn't it?
What's not your fault?
You're stupid, really?
It's not your fault.
Oh, stupid little guy.
We were just programmed that way, just like how Jessica
Rabbit was drawn sexy.
You can't help it.
I hope to be a stupid little guy.
You're the Jessica rabbit of stupid guys.
I guess maybe I'll do this puzzle and then we'll leave it.
You're alive!
Yeah!
You're just getting a test ready for you.
Me!
Who else would I be doing it for?
No one?
So, let's see here.
Exit, exit, exit.
Exit.
There is no exit.
Not a problem.
I'll just, I'll make an exit for your test.
Thank you.
Oh, it's so cool.
What the?
Isn't that one of the co-op guys?
I thought I lost you.
We're poking around for other test subjects.
No luck there.
Everyone's still dead.
That was one of the co-op guys.
I did find something though.
Reminds me.
I've got a big surprise for you too.
What's that?
Oh, is that the part where he kills us?
That's probably the part where he kills us, huh?
You know, I have to wonder, why don't they use the goo
anymore?
Can I fall through here?
So close.
Um, why don't they use the goo with the experiments anymore?
Like the goo that makes you fast?
The goo that makes you jump?
Oh, there's a little hole here.
Oh?
What's happening?
Why'd that happen?
I didn't- I didn't- I didn't expect- I didn't expect-
Am I a... Am I a prophet?
How long does this last for?
Ever?
Three, two, one.
Okay.
wield it into existence.
And now I want to play the co-op, because what if there's
like a cutscene of this part?
Wait, that's kind of fun.
That's not kind of fun.
That's really fun.
Alright, let's see.
What are we doing in here?
Gotta go fast.
Gotta stand still.
What is this one?
Wait, I don't recognize that one at all.
Okay.
Cool.
Oh, wait, the goo, the goo, the goo!
Gotta get gooed!
Why did I say that about the goo when it's literally right
here?
Guys, I didn't mean to do that at all.
That's so funny.
I need to, like, launch it, though.
Is there any way to make more goo, please?
Actually, why am I going fast?
Unless?
Run, run, run!
That's so funny that I say that, and then I'm literally
like, oh, there's goo right here.
The goo that makes it go fast.
Did I see that and subconsciously thinking?
I'm flabbergasted.
Okay, good.
Not good, but you know what I mean.
Aha!
Oh, there's this here.
We need to fling ourselves over there.
Of some sort.
Or some thing.
What if I press it again?
Oh, okay, okay.
It just makes a new one.
Very cool.
Um, there's like just not enough of this, right?
Whoa.
Needed
us.
That says 15 out of 19, but I don't trust the numbers.
You know?
What's up here, anyway?
Wait, can I go over there?
Wait, can I?
Wait, this is the exit, no?
Let's see what's going on over here.
A whole lot of nothing.
Just a...
Just a thing to reset my...
I feel...
Like, I need to launch and have this probably be going,
right?
Or of some sort?
I should be able to pass through here, right?
And then take me over?
That's what I'm guessing.
Are you enjoying this?
You sicko!
Watching me like the voyeur you are!
Sick!
I'm trying to...
Oh, this one's kind of tough, isn't it?
We have fast goo, but for what?
And I can't really, like, go so fast with it, you know?
Because it's only right here.
There's no way to...
to portal it elsewhere.
Do, do, do, do, do, do, do, do, do, do, do, do, do, do, do,
do, do, do, do, do, do, do,
Can I launch myself?
What the?
Oh, I launched myself somehow.
Yeah, I did that.
Okay.
I think we are going to get the bouncy goo.
Look at that.
It's right there.
And also no drinking.
This one's tough.
Like, do I fall?
And then boom.
Like that.
I think I can try.
Okay.
need orange, right?
Orange.
Oh, that was anticlimactic.
Oh, wait, how did I get it before?
Oh, my gosh.
My...
How did I do it before so perfectly?
You guys saw that, no?
What if I orange up a little higher?
Can we get much higher?
Oh, but It doesn't really work, does it?
I think I'm overthinking it with that.
But it does- oh, it disappears immediately.
Wait!
Where did my- oh.
Oops.
Okay, now it shouldn't go into the portal though.
Yeah!
Hmm.
Oh, for some reason I thought this was a platform right
here.
I was like, oh, I could just like portal up here and walk
over.
What is this for?
It feels like I need it here, no?
You know what I mean?
Like to go super fast on the ramp.
Like I feel like that's what this setup is for.
this will just take me over I don't know I don't know
I could always do this part next time with a pair of fresh
eyes
but it is quite curious now isn't it
I feel like they wouldn't have these high up if I wasn't
supposed to do like a jump down, launch myself over there
type of scenario, you know what I mean?
Let's try again one more time.
If I match these up well, enough.
Right?
That seems good.
And then when I get through here...
Wait, no.
Oh, when I'm falling, I portal blue.
Okay.
Falling portal blue to...
To...
Oh, it's upside down, that's why.
I did it.
Nobody can say I didn't do it.
I did it!
I just died, actually.
Getting a test ready for you, obviously.
Who else would I be doing it for?
No one.
So, let's see.
I wonder if the other...
If the other little guy is around too.
I'll just make an exit for your test.
The shorter one.
The round one.
Look, he's just standing there!
Looney tunes out of there.
I'll be honest, after you told me to turn that beam off, I
thought I had lost you.
We're poking around for other test subjects.
No luck there.
Everyone's still dead.
Oh, I did find something, though.
reminds me, I've got a big surprise for you two.
Seriously, look forward to it.
Is this going to lift up?
When does this lift up?
Maybe when we press the button.
Oh, it does, yeah.
Oh, it eats all the garbage.
Wow!
I was wondering where all that went.
Wow.
Alright, well, I feel like...
I had the right idea.
Just, um...
I launched too hard.
Perhaps.
Perhaps I...
need to not launch so crazy.
So what if we do...
Blue?
Orange.
Blue.
Oops.
Oh, that was a good thing I haven't missed.
Blue?
Blue.
Oh.
Dang it.
Okay.
Wait, maybe this needs to be back a little tiny bit.
There we go, there we go.
That's perfect.
Oh, uh...
Blue.
Like that?
Maybe.
Blue.
Oof.
We're gonna have to listen to his whole stupid spiel again.
Ah, shut up, shut up, shut up, shut up.
Just getting a test ready.
Blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah.
Blah, blah, blah.
So let's see here.
Exit, exit, exit.
There is no exit.
Good.
It's so funny.
Okay, I think I have the right idea, but wrong execution
perhaps.
No luck there.
Everyone's still dead.
Oh, I did find something though.
Reminds me.
I've got a big surprise for you two.
Seriously, look forward to it.
I felt like this past time, had I been quicker, I maybe
could have landed into a portal in there.
But it would have been tough.
It would have been tough.
I think this one we will come back with a fresh set of eyes
um I don't know if next one will be the last part or second
to last part exciting but thank you guys for joining me for
this part of portal 2 we're so close to finishing just a
couple more puzzles left I'll come back like I said with a
pair of well wrestled eyes and well-rested brain and see
what we can do with all of this.
Yeah.
Oh, Sumito everybody!
Thank you so much.
Thank you!
One more time, one more time.
What if like...
Okay.
Oh.
Uh...
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
My system, my system.
It must be orange here.
And blue here.
Okay, okay, yeah.
Watch this.
Why is it not working anymore?
Why?
Oh, live.
Oh,
the ground.
Oh, my god.
Awesome, everyone.
Bye.